oui elle a l'alerte à la bombe a été
levée pour le moment c'est pourquoi
maintenant vous voyez plus de gens dans
la rue dans le centre de Kiev et je me
suis moi-même rendu sur le site de
l'impact de l'un des missiles on se
trouve là sur la rue volody mirska
centre de Kiev je pense que vous voyez
derrière moi ou peut-être oui vous voyez
derrière les forces de l'autre et les
autres journalistes le cratère on ne
peut pas vraiment plus centrale en
réalité à Kévé puis juste devant moi ce
que vous ne voyez pas c'est le parc chef
c'est un parc dont le centre de Kiev où
je pense que toutes les personnes qui
vivent dans cette ville ont un moment
donné fait une balade on se parc bu un
café dans ce parc donc il n'y a pas un
habitant de Kiev aujourd'hui qui ne peut
pas penser cela aurait pu être moi si le
missile était tombé à un autre moment
clairement c'est quelque chose qui
augmente le niveau de peur donc la ville
est un peu sous le choc mais le message
aussi que j'ai entendu des personnes à
qui parlait notamment dans une station
de métro où ils étaient à l'abri c'était
un message de défiance et de colère et
surtout d'appel à l'Occident d'envoyer
plus d'armes et plus de système de
défense anti-aériens à l'Ukraine les
systèmes de défense anti-aériens qui
selon leur porte-parole aurait abattu
près de la moitié des missiles qui
étaient
envoyés par l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
voilà les renseignements
Ukrainiens qui sont en train de
s'exprimer et qui font savoir que cet
opération avait été planifiée déjà
depuis le début du mois d'octobre
Gulliver comment les Ukrainiens
interprètent-ils aujourd'hui cette
offensive russe on a parlé tout à
l'heure de ce pont de Crimée qui a été
pris pour cible ce week-end on sait que
ça a fait ça fait bon dire d'orage
Vladimir Poutine qui sait d'ailleurs
exprimé ce matin qui a réagi estimant
qu'il ne pouvait qu'il ne pouvait pas
laisser cet événement sans réponse
oui je pense que beaucoup d'Ukrainiens
ils voient une réponse au bombardement
du pont de Crimée et ils ont
l'impression que la Russie répond par la
terreur depuis très longtemps les
Ukrainiens accusent la Russie de semer
la terreur en Ukraine et de vouloir
cibler expressément des civils c'est
juste de plus en plus le cas aujourd'hui
il y a plus en plus d'évidence on se
sens si d'autres attaques ou des civils
ont péri depuis le 24 février dans
beaucoup de cas on pouvait y décerner un
cible militaire ou un cible
d'infrastructures critiques au moins non
loin de l'endroit de l'attaque ce n'est
vraiment pas le cas quand on parle de
missiles qui sont tombés dans le dans le
plein centre de Kiev à côté d'un parc a
été université alors cela confirme
vraiment ce que beaucoup d'Ukrainiens
disaient depuis assez longtemps qui est
que la Russie à l'intention de semer la
terreur parmi les Ukrainiens l'une des
analyses qui est fait c'est que Vladimir
Poutine a encore espoir que les
Ukrainiens vont décider il faut en
réalité pour arrêter tout cela aller à
chercher un compromis avec Vladimir
Poutine mais je pense que je pense que
la plupart des Ukrainiens en ce moment
dirait qu'il se trompe gravement si
c'est vraiment c'est la qu'il pense
merci beaucoup Gulliver Craig